Foundry definitely makes it easier on being completely honest
Well, but if you just know your character shape for the normal things
Anyway, 21
Nice
But the 24 hit didn't hit neck last time
I kept taking the guy right up to me. I was taking you all night
Sticks
But this is that you did
Yeah
Yep
Hey
Yeah, cuz I actually need to get my turn I can't move anymore
Yeah, I just need me and the third
Cuz I'm stupid like that
Yep, that we
Yep
Okay, and I asked this last touch, but the rule
Who's on the double group spells
One slap the third one slap that did three for first
That's what you did
Oh, that was that was my um
Lunarion ability, so I still have my dog fruit
Molotel is my Lunarion
Oh my god, he was trying to cheat me
Yeah, my boat, yeah, I got the striped thing
I was about to cry
Cry baby boy
Okay, I command the
Okay, um, well this okay
See I
This becomes so much more difficult
This will let me attack twice what more time this will be able to okay
Guys gods be with me today
I'm not gambling yet. I just need I need things to work out today. Okay
First attack
Oh my god, he's a no
Family
Dunning strike
I
Can't do this
Third attack
Damage
Dunning strike
Do I give an excitement
Is this my last one
Three
Eighteen
I have four attacks
No, I don't why am I thinking why are you lying?
You just straight applying
He's only one extra attack
Did you use haste?
That is my
I'm done
Two
No, no using three
No, oh
Yeah, forgot I had a bird
I could have done a whole attack
Do we do
I
I ate it here
Wrecked the fire
Yeah, it's level 15
I could really use
Yeah
Nope
Love when the team asked to obvious
I am the assistant
Yep
I think I'm going to
I know
That hurts
Give me one second to decide
In your turn
Six seconds to decide actually
Give me a minute
I think we both know this isn't going to go that way
So let's just get this over with
I'm using my
The test yield
Five
Like I don't know nip the void
To like make this life
Disappear
And then reappear once it's
What
It should dirty his
Well, athletics or acrobatics
Why
How would you just confidant you like you want to kill
First
Oh, yeah, come on
Yeah
The role is the same
Naturally
Can I stack resistances
I'm a Lunarian and then my elemental domain
You call me double resistant to something
If I get double resistant that gives me a new
Wait a second what
Who did we use the push node
My god
Yeah, thanks Bob
I think he should do a short check to see if he can grab him
Thank
Well
Holy shit this guy is awesome
Kyle move away
Oh
I only got this guy so a cool number time
Here you go
There's an check
Boom boom boom
He's 18 hit
Holy shit
Does
Okay, fuck me, oh shit
We are doomed, we are doomed
Does it count you one hit
Okay, so that will be one deep
How do I do one deep there's less one deep 10
Where is the polar master where the hell is
Why is this so
Ah, I'll just do the little
The polar master
Yeah
I don't know I'm doing it and doing the role
I don't want to do the normal damage because that will be one deep 10 plus 13
But I have to do one deep plus 13 and then I'm just gonna throw a pretty simple
Level two
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
Not have an ender here
Like a humble level to advance my flip
Zoom spell slot
Do the damage roll
And that's a 15 so 30 damage
So that's why
Knock him out
First like first damage this guy just comes and slashes his like he had a pistol right pistol out of the way and then Bob just bomb
It's all over him and that future smoke that turns him to like get unconscious
He's like how a dragon breeds fire all things breathing blood
And that's the end of his turn
Yeah
And this one I've been heading this whole time
And other one
Knock him out
Oh I'm making me look bad
Alright I'll get him
Yeah I'm gonna kill him
He did
He just died
He's just a weak and that needs to be on the other guy
Let's go
Well fuck off
Let's see
It's our guys, yes, images
I go read
Yep that's me
I am the dark one the land
Go about this
I'm not going to do that
I'm still going to do
Because we don't back down around here
Okay
Oh my god
I don't roll above 10 damage
Okay, left
Is that a look?
Oh okay
So that is my turn
You're not going to use flurry of blue stunning strike nothing
Okay
Okay, sorry
I'm sorry
No that'll be my turn
Okay
What are you doing?
You're scaring us
Who is this guy attacking?
Oh, there he is
There is no third one
There is no war in passing, say
Oh, there there will be a third one
I think it missed
Yeah
That's like the DM successful
Yeah, that's done
Oh no
Oh
Is it bandaged by the way?
It's ranged
Yeah, yeah
Oh fuck no
Well, wait
No
He doesn't hit
Oh, I'm so I am somewhere else right now
Well, it gets
And then have to buy
Okay
So I take zero
That's fine
You don't have any friends left
Look around
Yeah, not the forest much longer
Okay
Kyle
Oh, yeah
Go Kyle
Holy fuck yes, Kyle
Well, he does I am trying to make sure he doesn't have any friends
So one trick pony does a what
What what what what what isn't what what what confused what's happening
What isn't it rolling
You have lost connection on the server great why do I do every time it's my turn
Rob is now
Can you click on attack for God's sake just click on attack and do advantage
Yeah, it's just not letting me
Okay, do let me do it
Okay, nope, he okay, this is getting scary this is getting scary
Let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me let me just here and boom and then and then and then just and then just a Doom Doom Doom Boom doesn't I know
Fuck, Bob is just lashing and slashing but this guy fuck this
You wanna fuck him no, he can't no he can't target it so he can't even if he wants to
Everyone's I know he did
Yeah, that's my three or that's
Yeah, I should
Yeah, he 26
Two nights
Another one
Great
Another one that's normal and he's to be with advantage
Oh, that's a quit
And pick
Oh, that's what my damage against
Is it 11 plus 5 at the thick scene 16 whole damage from one create let's go
Yeah, I don't do damage no, I did my three attacks
Three one with the punches
Is he still up Hello
Hello 21
You said kill was stabbing him in the back right
I want to punch his chest and then as soon as I punch him in the chest
It's like pushing him backwards onto the sword and then I want to grab the sword and pull it through even more
He did so I'm punching with my arms and then the void arms are like pulling the sword forward
So he's really been pushed both ways
Oh, that's a spin to me
Yeah, I'm so glad I asked
I used one double figure so first level is one second level is two six third level is three uses right
And use my last two uses
It's 30 feet in this piece of your why is it why am I covered by dice what's going on
What's not going this way
30 feet
All right, so miss the step then use my movement to just catch up
That's it
All right, we're punching
We do be punchers
I'm not being stupid about it
That is good
So as soon as like he disappears and like teleports over there
That he's like out for shifting the void so he followed himself through the void so he just disappears from there
He's still the boy over there and then just charges up and wax him in the back of the head
So I don't think he knew that he was able to follow him so he just catches up
And gets him in concussion block force trauma to the head
Bad like a sheep
Oh, it's so hard, oh difficult, that's what
I'm in the void
Am I the bad start
Who is he hitting where is that I think you're standing on top of him
No, I'm
I don't care if the concentrate on that ball of hell nobody's over there
Oh god
If we don't get the level of after this
I mean
That's the three that hits the light
What if it doesn't
What for
I think it's burning
What many of the stand runs
I'm just doing this for fun
I'm just doing this for fun with my banding overtime
I'm just doing this for fun with my banding
He's yelling out to Baptiste
I said the vibe worse
Okay, so I was going to help you but never mind then
That is not it
I should stop doing that
I should definitely stop doing that
Let me just turn it off
There's no point
See Bob you're better than me
I will keep doing it
We know you would
If you would have kept it right there
Let me real quick
Yeah, that's why I can't gamble but you can
And now let me just do I have it?
Yeah, I have a real humble level two
There it is, level two
If I'm smart, do the damage, do the roll
That's it, 11
And then my last polar master bonus section where is it?
No, I do not want to end his life, I am a good person
I'm a chaotic new true good person
Well, he has been jumping around a lot
So Bob just meshes his head
So, false to the floor and Bob goes
No more teleporting from for you now
Because if I can't teleport anymore neither can you
What is this guy?
Okay, so he just didn't take the damage?
Okay, let me...
Yeah, okay, so is this guy who is this guy?
Oh, I don't give a shit about this guy
I don't care about him
He just came over here real quick
Hey, so who are you supposed to be Mr. Side Character?
What?
It's okay, it's the only way back
Where is the polar master? Why is it turned?
Hey, just wait a second till I find my polar master
Let me just do that over here
Does the 22 hit?
Oh shit, did I move last...
Okay, I moved last time
Sorry, sorry, nothing happens, nothing happens, sorry
I'm stupid, nothing happens
I didn't even move there
I didn't do what I was doing
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
So Bob just doesn't move
He...
This guy teleported
That's the end of his turn
Wait a second, wait a second
Do you have my bonus action still, right?
Is playoff and spawn?
No, it's an action
So, never mind
No, it's not bonus action
It's bonus action into 2024
But it's not in 2024 game
Anyway, I'm ahead of him
Get up, you...
Wow, what a damage
Woohoo
Go again
Oh, great
Hmm, great
Well, that's it
Oh, daddy
We need that onto, we can't let this guy go
And he's gonna move a whole speed by...
Because he's carrying someone
Right?
Oh, yeah
We gotta be fair
Malfi was supposed to be moving your hand speed this whole time too
Well, I dropped the bag
Oh, when did you drop the bag?
Well, I was supposed to try that on your own, daddy
Hmm, I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I'm going to get the ad. Or I gave it to the dude. Yeah, somewhere there, probably. Yeah.
Yeah, go ahead. I kind of forgot about it.
Is it the clone or not? It's our mess.
I'm just going to go ahead.
Yeah, let's 20 hit.
One more. 18 doesn't hit, right?
I'm really doing the punches with such little eyes, but like who cares?
Who the fuck is this 19 it? This is why we do what we do. Oh, why did I do it?
I just wasted a crit. I don't mind. I wasted my crit.
He's.
Yeah, Mr. Captain.
Yeah, I'm going to die. Okay.
I want a punch on to where he falls on top of his captain. Six lonely.
Okay, yuck.
Oh, okay. You don't have to do the voice acting for that.
Yeah, and you're using it on this. No, no, loud. Or maybe I can get right there to
do it. I was still technically mouthless as turn so I can't move.
Yeah, I don't know why I'm invisible.
Well, I use some punches. I can't walk over his dead body.
Move that. That's the case. I'm still like five back.
Oh, no, I'm right there. Never mind.
Yeah.
I'm going to be a dash.
While mouth is face for him, I would like to look for the bag that he doesn't have on him
anymore.
What? No, he doesn't know where it is.
No.
I don't know where it is.
Well, the back. The back. You so many before comba starters. Let's. Okay. Let's. It's not bad. It's right over here. If I'm right here. Thank you.
Thank you. Okay.
Okay. Godspeed. Godspeed.
Six feet is my base movements. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. I'll burn his action.
He's blending in with you. Don't let him escape.
They don't know he took.
What the fuck?
You know it. You can actually do it if you want. 25. I mean, it's almost there. Right. It's a 19 on the dice.
Well, we still have the other level up.
Let's go inside.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, no.
Yeah.
What?
Hello.
I was saying like, are we taking this guys for their bounty?
Yeah.
Well, we can't get you. So do you want this guy?
How are you going to take two people away? Two people?
Look, Baptists. I don't really care about these two, but we need the captain. But the rest two is that zero order.
I don't care. Let them take those two.
Yeah. Well, he's not that big of a part captain. His crew is pretty tiny, but yeah.
I don't know sometimes.
Dude, hey, hey, Eric guy. You don't have a captain right now, right?
Yeah. So what will happen to your crew?
Yeah.
Well, Eric farewell and he waves his hand and get out of here, please.
Nope.
Yeah.
Well, I have a plan since pirates, we won't be able to really submit the bounty for this captain, but over to.
Shit the fuck up.
Yeah.
And you have wings.
And don't you need it, huh?
Well, consider it this way.
Yeah.
We'll just say you can tell me after the session.